we now continue our discussion of
infinite series sometimes we have to
deal with series where the terms being
added are indexed by multiple indices as
in this example here we are given
numbers a I J and I ranges over all the
positive integers J also ranges over all
the positive integers so what does this
sum represent we can think of it as
follows we have here the 2-dimensional
grid that corresponds to all the pair's
I J and in essence each one of those
points corresponds to one of the terms
that we want to add so we can sum the
different terms in some arbitrary order
let's say we start from here take that
term add this term then add this term
here then add this term then the next
term next term and so on and we can keep
going that way adding the different
terms in according to some sequence so
essentially what we are doing here is
we're taking this two-dimensional grid
and arranging the terms associated with
that grid in some particular linear
order and were summing those terms in
sequence as long as this sum converges
to something as we keep adding more and
more terms then this double series will
be well-defined notice however we can
add those terms in many different orders
and in principle those different orders
might give us different kinds of results
on the other hand as long as the sum of
the absolute values of all the terms
turns out to be finite then the
particular order in which we are adding
the different terms will turn out that
it doesn't matter there's another way
that we can add the terms together and
this is the following let us consider
fixing a particular choice of AI
and adding all the terms that are
associated with this particular choice
of I as J ranges from one to infinity so
what we're doing is we're taking the
summation from J equal to 1 to infinity
while keeping the value of I fixed we do
this for every possible I so for every
possible I we're going to get a
particular number and then we take the
numbers that we obtain for the different
choices of I so I ranges from 1 to
infinity and we add all those terms
together so this is one particular order
one particular way of doing the infinite
summation now why start with a summation
over J's while keeping eye fixed there's
no reason for that we could also carry
out the summation by fixing a particular
choice of J and summing over all eyes so
now it is I that ranges from 1 to
infinity and we look at this infinite
sum this is the infinite sum of those
terms we obtain one such infinite sum
for every choice of J and then we take
that son that we obtain for any
particular choice of J and add over the
different possible values of J so J goes
from 1 to infinity this is a different
way of carrying out the summation and
these are going to give us the same
result and the same result that we would
also obtain if we were to add the terms
in this particular order as long as the
double series is well defined in the
following sense if we have a guarantee
that the sum of the absolute values of
those numbers is finite no matter which
way we add them then it turns out that
we can use any particular order to add
the terms in the series we're going to
get the same result and
we can also carry out the double the
double summation by doing by adding over
one index at a time
a word of caution this condition is not
always satisfied and in those cases
strange things can happen suppose that
are the sequence that we're dealing with
the AI J's take those particular values
indicated in this picture and all the
remaining terms the a IJ is associated
with the other dots are all zeros so all
these terms out there will be zeros if
we carry out the summation by fixing a J
and adding over all eyes what we get
here is 0 + 0 + 0 + 0 that's because in
each row we have a 1 and the minus 1
which cancel out and give us zeros so if
we carry out the summation in this
manner we get a sum of zeros which is 0
but if we carry out the summation in
this order fix an AI and then add over
all J's the first term that we get here
is going to be 1 because in this column
there's all this is the only nonzero
number and then in the remaining columns
as we add the terms we're going to get
zeros and zeros and so on and so if we
carry out the summation in this way we
obtain a 1 so this is an example that
shows you that the order of summation
actually may matter in this example the
sum of the absolute values of all the
terms that are involved is infinity
because we have infinitely many plus or
minus ones so this condition here is not
satisfied in this example let us now
consider the case where we want to add
the terms of a double sequence but
over a limited range of indices as in
this example where we have coefficients
a IJ which we want to add but only for
those eyes and J is for which J is less
than or equal to I graphically this
means that we only want to consider the
pairs shown in this picture so these
points here correspond to IJ pairs for
which I is equal to J terms on the right
or points to the right correspond to IJ
pairs for which I is at least as large
as J we can carry out this summation in
two ways one way is the following we fix
the value of I and we consider all the
corresponding terms that correspond to
different choices of J but we only go up
to the point where I is equal to J this
is the largest term so what are we doing
here we're taking the coefficients a IJ
and we are adding over all J's starting
from 1 which corresponds to this term
and J goes up to the point where it
becomes equal to AI we do this for every
value of AI and so we get a number for
the sum of each one of the columns and
then we add those numbers together so
we're adding over all eyes and eye
ranges from 1 up to infinity this is one
way of carrying out the summation
alternatively we could fix the value of
J and consider doing the summation over
all choices of I so this corresponds to
the sum over all choices of AI from
where the smallest term the first term
happens when I is equal to the value of
J and then we have larger choices of I
numbers for which I is bigger than the
corresponding value of J and so I ranges
from J or
the way to infinity and this is the sum
over one of the rows in this diagram we
do this for every J we get a result and
then we need to add all those results
together so we are summing for all J's
from 1 up to infinity so these are two
different ways that we can evaluate this
series associated with a double sequence
we can either add overall J's first and
then over eyes or we can sum over all
eyes first and then over all J's the two
ways of approaching this problem this
summation should give us the same answer
and this is going to be again subject to
the usual qualification as long as the
sum of the absolute values of the terms
that we are trying to add is less than
infinity if this condition is true then
the two ways of carrying out the
summation are equal and they're just two
different alternatives